Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Negli anni '90, c'era un detto
che caratterizzava Internet,
cioè che "Su Internet,
nessuno sa se sei un cane".
E l'obiettivo di quel detto
era far capire, appunto,
come fosse facile
essere anonimi su Internet.
Questa cosa negli anni è cambiata molto.
Secondo me, l'anno che più caratterizza
questo cambiamento è stato il 2008.
La domanda che mi pongo oggi con voi,
e che mi pongo da tempo, è:
nel futuro, nel 2020, o anche più in là,
saremo sempre più anonimi o avremo
sempre meno anonimato su Internet?
E quale delle due opzioni
possiamo considerare essere la migliore?
Ora, la prima questione è:
cosa è successo nel 2008?
Nel 2008 è successa
una cosa molto interessante.
Cioè che i social network sono diventati
un fenomeno sociale sempre più grande.
E i social network - in maniera indiretta,
questo non era il loro obiettivo -
ma in maniera indiretta
hanno reso sempre più difficile
essere anonimi su Internet.
Se giocate a poker,
nel mondo del poker c'è un detto
che fa capire perché questo fenomeno
della mancanza di privacy
sia in parte dovuto ai social network.
Il detto è che se ad un tavolo di poker,
entro i primi cinque minuti
non capite chi è il pollo,
il pollo siete voi.
In questo caso, il prodotto
di questi social network siamo tutti noi.
Nel senso che i social network,
quasi tutti,
guadagnano attraverso un industria
che è l'industria dell'advertising.
Il nesso logico tra le due industrie,
che sembrano molto poco connesse,
è il fatto che l'obiettivo
dell'industria dell'advertising
è vendere a tutti noi dei prodotti;
e i social network, così come
molte altre aziende tecnologiche,
hanno un quantitativo di dati
su di noi quasi allucinante.
L'idea è che,
se riusciamo a usare questi dati
per capire meglio cosa interessa
al singolo consumatore,
allora avremo una più alta probabilità
di convincere quel consumatore
a spendere dei soldi.
Il mercato dell'advertising
sono circa 529 miliardi di dollari l'anno,
che è una cifra incredibile.
Stiamo parlando del PIL
di un paese come il Belgio.
E a questo fenomeno, che è un fenomeno
puramente economico,
si aggiunge un altro problema.
L'altro problema
è un problema più psicologico.
Cioè che negli anni
sono state fatte diverse ricerche
in cui si è provato
che un utente, una persona,
fra scegliere privacy o sicurezza,
e scegliere il comfort o la comodità,
quasi sempre sceglierà
il comfort o la comodità,
se la percezione del rischio
è una percezione remota.
Cioè, se non consideriamo il rischio
come una cosa molto probabile,
allora molto probabilmente
preferiremo il comfort
alla sicurezza o alla privacy.
La realtà dei fatti, però,
è che se io ora
vi chiedessi di spogliarvi,
quanti di voi sarebbero disposti a farlo?
Credo nessuno.
Il motivo di questa cosa
è che, chiaramente, voi percepite,
anche io percepirei questa situazione
come una situazione pericolosa.
Nel senso che l'imbarazzo, il pudore,
mi farebbero stare abbastanza male
se decidessi di spogliarmi.
Il punto è che su Internet,
noi ci spogliamo quotidianamente
e siamo "protetti", tra virgolette,
o abbiamo questo senso di falsa sicurezza,
che ci è dato dal fatto
che questi social network,
e buona parte dei siti che noi visitiamo,
sono difficili da capire
per il singolo utente;
e allo stesso tempo, di nuovo,
ci danno questo finto senso della privacy.
Ora, Borat è un modo simpatico
di spiegare il problema.
La realtà è che sempre
più spesso, negli anni,
vediamo soprattutto adolescenti suicidarsi
per quello che i loro compagni di scuola
postano su Facebook,
piuttosto che su altri social network.
C'è un ulteriore problema:
che non solo siamo nudi,
e la gente ci guarda
quando siamo su Internet,
ma tutto quello che noi facciamo
viene registrato constantemente.
Di nuovo, cercando di fare
una paragone con la vita reale,
è come se viveste a Londra.
Per quanti di voi siano andati a Londra,
c'è pieno di telecamere.
Quindi ogni giorno noi
ci svegliamo nella nostra vita online,
compiamo tutti i nostri gesti
che possono essere andare su Facebook,
piuttosto che guardare
il nostro conto in banca, eccetera
siamo completamente nudi
e siamo registrati.
Ora, il punto è che,
quando parlo di registrazione,
intendo dire circa
600 terabyte di dati al giorno.
Se volessimo trasformare questo
in ore video,
parleremmo di 150.000 film
da due ore ciascuno.
Se uno di noi volesse analizzare o vedere
questi dati che vengono raccolti
in un giorno solo,
da un'azienda sola, cioè da Facebook,
ci servirebbero 35 anni.
Che è, almeno pensandoci,
è una cosa incredibile
perché, di nuovo, ogni giorno
è come se Facebook raccogliesse
35 anni di ore video su tutti noi.
La domanda, chiaramente, è:
perché mi dovrebbe interessare?
Come singolo cittadino,
come singolo utente, perché mi interessa?
Perché alla fine, questo sistema
funziona in maniera perfetta
per tutti noi.
Nel senso che è il tipico
fenomeno del free-riding.
Nel senso che noi usufruiamo
di servizi in maniera gratuita
e questi servizi
migliorano la nostra vita.
Quindi la domanda che ci poniamo è:
questo è un problema,
o saràun problema in futuro?
La mia risposta è sì.
Uno dei problemi che abbiamo,
con questa raccolta frenetica di dati,
è il fatto che, come dicevo prima,
nessun umano è in grado di analizzare
questi quantitativi di dati
che vengono raccolti quotidianamente.
Per cui facciamo affidamento
alle macchine.
Nello specifico, facciamo affidamento
a degli algoritmi che si chiamano
algoritmi di machine learning.
Ora, mi perdoneranno
i cultori della materia,
ma il machine learning
è fondamentalmente la statistica
applicata a grandi quantitativi di dati
attraverso dei computer.
Il problema della statistica
è che la statistica, per sua natura,
ha un errore intrinseco.
E quindi, uno dei problemi
che ci poniamo spesso,
che chi si occupa della materia si pone,
è come fare a minimizzare questo errore;
perché altrimenti, quando uso
l'algoritmo di machine learning,
è probabile che io faccia
delle deduzioni sbagliate
su una determinata persona.
Gli algoritmi
di machine learning, tendenzialmente,
vengono usati per due cose.
La prima cosa è classificare delle entità,
cioè dire: "Questa persona
è un uomo o una donna",
"Questa persona è ricca o povera",
eccetera.
L'altra cosa è imparare
delle cose su qualcuno,
in maniera tale -
di nuovo, se lo guardiamo
dal punto di vista dell'advertising,
per capire cosa può interessare
a un determinato utente.
C'è un problema con tutto ciò.
Questo significa che noi,
fondamentalmente,
stiamo dando in outsourcing
delle decisioni sempre più importanti,
sulla vita di tutti di giorni,
a delle macchine.
Ora, in generale una cosa
che gli algoritmi di machine learning
non riescono a fare oggi,
e probabilmente
non riusciranno mai a fare,
è che non hanno empatia.
Quindi se noi abbiamo
questo stream di dati,
che va dal giorno
in cui siamo nati a oggi,
e come tutti quanti abbiamo commesso
degli errori in passato,
o ci sono delle cose
che preferiremmo non menzionare,
l'algoritmo di machine learning
non considera niente di tutto ciò.
L'algoritmo di machine learning
ha dei dati, fa l'analisi sui dati,
ci dà delle risposte.
In più,
la probabilità che uno a caso di noi
capisca effettivamente cosa fa l'algoritmo
è praticamente pari allo zero.
Anzi è quasi preoccupante,
perché se parlate
con una persona qualunque
che si occupa di reti neurali,
vi diràche determinate decisioni,
che migliorano i risultati
delle reti neurali,
non hanno una spiegazione.
Nel senso che vengono,
vengono cambiati dei parametri
e perché quei parametri
dovrebbero funzionare meglio di altri
è una domanda a cui
nessuno ha una risposta.
Ci ritroveremo in un futuro,
purtroppo molto più vicino
di quanto pensiamo,
ad avere a che fare con delle istituzioni
che usano questi algoritmi
per prendere delle decisioni importanti
sulla vita di tutti i giorni.
E per il problema di cui sopra,
non saremo in grado
di confutare queste decisioni.
Ora, questo non credo
succeda molto in Italia,
ma succeda tantissimo
negli Stati Uniti.
Nel senso che il machine learning,
applicato a quello che di solito
viene definito big data,
viene utilizzato giàoggi
per capire quanto dev'essere alto
il premio assicurativo sulla salute.
Viene utilizzato per capire
quanto deve essere alto
il tasso d'interesse sul vostro mutuo
e se darvi, un mutuo.
Viene utilizzato dai governi
per correlare le attivitàdi persone,
per capire se quelle persone
sono state coinvolte
in qualche attentato,
piuttosto che qualunque
altro atto criminale.
Ora, un autore molto famoso
di fantascienza, William Gibson,
ha scritto di recente su Twitter
che una delle domande
che lui si pone spesso,
quando vede della nuova tecnologia,
è: "Cosa farebbe la Corea del Nord,
se avesse accesso a questa tecnologia?"
Il punto è che noi, implicitamente,
stiamo creando una tecnologia
che non capiamo
e che potenzialmente darebbe,
a un paese come la Corea del Nord,
la possibilitàdi creare l'equivalente
di uno stato totalitario su Internet.
Ciò detto, spesso, purtroppo,
nel mio lavoro sono foriero
di cattive notizie
e l'obiettivo di questo talk
è di cercare di avere
una visione costruttiva.
Perché, di nuovo, Internet
e lo sharing in generale,
ha migliorato in passato
e migliora le nostre vite tuttora.
E in termini molto pratici,
senza Internet io non avrei un lavoro,
per cui è importante
che Internet sopravviva
e che lo sharing sopravviva.
E inoltre, è importante la possibilità
di mantenere il concetto di free riding,
perché, altrimenti, quello
che viene definito il terzo mondo
non avrebbe accesso,
non avrebbe la possibilità di pagare
per le risorse su Internet
che noi tutti utilizziamo oggi.
Ci sono quattro cose che, secondo me,
possiamo fare come cittadini
per migliorare la situazione.
Alcune di queste richiedono
un lavoro di concerto
con le istituzioni e le aziende,
e altre invece sono delle cose
che possiamo fare noi singolarmente.
La prima cosa è imporre alle aziende
di avere una sorta di data di scadenza
sui dati che vengono raccolti.
Cioè, l'idea è:
ok, tu puoi raccogliere
tutti i dati che vuoi,
ma dopo 30 giorni, sei mesi, un anno,
quei dati devono necessariamente
essere cancellati.
Questo permette a noi di avere
il famoso diritto di essere dimenticati
e rende più difficile per le aziende
applicare degli algoritmi
su dei dati storici che, magari,
noi non avremmo voluto condividere
se avessimo saputo
che quel tipo di algoritmo
sarebbe stato utilizzato su questi dati.
La seconda proposta è quella
di avere delle etichette,
molto simili alle etichette
che abbiamo sul cibo,
cioè i valori nutrizionali del cibo.
Queste etichette devono essere appplicate
ai siti web e alle applicazioni,
sia sui cellulari, sia sul computer.
Perché?
Perché in realtà il metodo, legale,
attraverso il quale le aziende
si appropriano dei nostri dati
e fanno quello che vogliono
con i nostri dati,
sono questi contratti,
spesso chiamati EULA,
e questi contratti non sono fatti
per essere letti da esseri umani:
sono fatti da avvocati,
e l'obiettivo è rendere quasi impossibile
la lettura da parte di un essere umano.
In più, questi contratti
sono fatti in maniera tale
che fondamentalmente,
nel momento in cui noi
accediamo ad un sito,
o scarichiamo un'applicazione,
stiamo dando completo controllo
dei nostri dati
ad una determinata azienda.
Questa cosa sta cambiando lentamente
su, ad esempio,
sistemi operativi come iOS,
quindi quello che avete sui vostri iPhone.
Cioè, quando una determinata applicazione
vuole accedere alla telecamera,
piuttosto che ai contatti,
viene fuori un pop-up che vi chiede:
"Vuoi dare l'autorizzazione
a questa applicazione,
per accedere ai dati?"
Ma non è abbastanza.
Bisognerebbe anche rendere comprensibile
all'essere umano cosa si fa con quei dati.
La terza opzione è avere la possibiltà
di pagare per dei servizi.
Ad esempio, se voi siete
dei fruitori appassionati di Facebook,
dovreste poter avere due opzioni:
l'opzione gratuita, in cui Facebook
ha il diritto di collezionare i dati,
e l'opzione a pagamento, in cui voi pagate
o un abbonamento mensile,
oppure a consumo;
e però Facebook, a quel punto,
non deve essere in grado
di collezione i dati su di voi.
Ora, questa è una cosa
che sta giàaccadendo,
nel senso che ci sono dei servizi
sia di Google, sia di altre aziende
che si stanno muovendo più
in questa direzione.
Però ancora non è abbastanza.
La quarta opzione è l'unica cosa
che in realtàpotete fare giàda oggi,
quando andate a casa.
Cioè utilizzare dei tool
che sono privacy-friendly.
Cioè, sono dei tool
che rendono più difficile
il tracciamento delle persone su Internet.
Sono tool che bloccano i siti
che vi fanno vedere la pubblicità.
Sono dei tool come Tor.
Tor è più o meno un labirinto online
in modo tale che,
quando io vado su un sito,
è impossibile per il proprietario del sito
capire da dove viene la connessione.
Quindi è impossibile,
per il proprietario del sito,
capire che sono io.
Oppure potenzialmente,
qualcosa come Bitcoin,
che rende più difficile collegare
una transazione finanziaria
con una persona fisica.
Il problema dei tool di privacy
è che spesso vengono utilizzati
come uno spauracchio dai governi-
non solo dai governi totalitari,
ma anche dai nostri governi,
anche dai governi come l'Inghilterra,
perché siccome garantiscono
più confidenzialitàe più privacy,
vengono anche utilizzati
da terroristi e criminali
per le loro attività.
Il problema è che ad oggi,
questi sono gli unici tool
che noi abbiamo a disposizione
per proteggere noi stessi.
Per cui è importante che restino legali,
per quanto più tempo possibile,
finché questo tipo di problema
non verràrisolto.
Ora, la domanda è:
cosa succederàin futuro?
Be', io spero che nel 2020
avremo la possibilità
sia di essere dei cani su Internet,
sia, paradossalmente,
di avere più identitàsu Internet.
Cioè quasi un mapping uno a uno
fra la nostra identità virtuale
e la nostra identità reale
per poter fare cose come votare online,
oppure aprire un conto in banca
senza dover firmare
nessun tipo di contratto.
Il punto è che è fondamentale
avere la possibilità
di avere entrambe le cose,
altrimenti ci ritoveremo
in uno stato totalitario sul web.
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)